[Music]
in this video we are going to look at a
few key words that you will come across
throughout
ecology let's start by looking at the
whole thing the ecosystem an ecosystem
is made up of all the communities that
live in it every single organism from
Big to small and lots of environmental
factors like sunlight shade the Woodland
streams and other things an ecosystem is
defined as a biological community of
interacting organisms and their physical
environment a habitat is an area or
environment in which an organism
naturally lives so the Woodland in this
example it describes the geographical
area occupied by the ecosystem whereas
the ecosystem is the interactions
between everything living within it as
well as the non-living
factors populations are all members of
the same species in the habit had at one
time while populations describe just one
species a community is all of the
organisms in multiple species that
coexist in the habitat at one time so
the community is the foxes rabbits
insects plants fungi and everything else
living in the Woodland a niche describes
the role of a species within an
ecosystem so a bee's role is to
pollinate the flowers the rabbit's role
or Niche is to be a small grazing prey
animal with a very high reproduction
rate which supports many predators in
the ecosystem a species is a group of
potentially interbreeding individuals
which do not normally reproduce with
other species to produce viable fertile
offspring so here in our Woodland we
have foxes and rabbits that are clearly
different
species but we may also have a few
different species of
butterfly maybe one lives on the outside
of the woods and likes light while
another lives deeper in the
wood and because they prefer different
areas of the wood they don't interbreed
we will look at what it really means to
be a species in another video and we'll
also revisit all the words throughout
ecology for now you just need to know
the difference between a habitat and
ecosystem a population and a community
and how species have a niche within the
ecosystem